من الدوحه ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه
نايف سجين نايف يسعد صباحك مبروك اهلا بك
واضح من لبسك واضح مبروك يا نايف ومباراه
عظيمه مباراه مجنونه كيف كان الحماس كيف
كانت الاجواء امس في مباراه النهائيه
البطل بغض النظر عن
اخر لكن بالفعل يعني امس كانت المباراه
حماسيه جدا وقد يكون يعني السيناريو الذي
حدث في نهايه المباراه والتعادل يعني كثير
من الحماس والتفاعل في همم داخل الملعب
وخارج الملعب بالامس همم يعني خلال همم
طريقه همم الى الملعب شهاده يعني الاف من
الاشخاص يسوون باتجاه الملعب همم يعني
بالتاكيد ان العدد كان يفوق همم عدد
المدرجات 88,000 ولكن
نجحت في ان يكون هناك منطقه محاضره للملعب
تتسع لكل همم الجماهير لذلك من يملك دبكه
وذهب الى داخل الملعب ومن لا يملك تذكره
كان في همم
بوليفارد لوسيل هناك كانت شاشات وهنا هناك
كانت همم احتفالات طبعا امتدت اشواط
الاضافيه ثم الى ضربات الجزاء وكان هناك
يعني امور ملفته وامور جميله يعني همم
وجماهيريه مثاليه يعني كانت الجماهير
الارجنتينيه تحيي المنتخب الفرنسي وايضا
حيه امبابي عندما تم اعلانه هداف لبطوله
كاس العالم في المقابل كانت الجماهير
الفرنسيه تحيه ميسي وتحيي المنتخب
الارجنتيني ولكن يعني اللقطه او المشهد
ال- ال- ال- المختلف عندما قام ميسي بجانب
كاس العالم ووضع اصابع يده وقبل كاس
العالم في هذا المشهد كانت شاشات الداخليه
تعوض اللقطات وهاتف واهتز الملعب باهتافات
الجمهور
الارجنتيني هناك يعني همم طريقه في همم
تحفيز ميسي استخدم الجمهور الارجنتيني عبر
تنديد
نايف راح نرجع لك كثير
سنعود اليك في تويتر